Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo episodio di Sons of
the forest che mi sta piacendo veramente
un casino e dire tutta questa frase
senza prendere mai un respiro è
incredibile Spero che stia facendo anche
a voi vi giuro che è divertentissimo
perché ci sono un sacco di misteri
rispetto al primo e in questo episodio
Ne vedrete tantissimi perché sto andando
avanti dei incredibile Let's go my boys
bravissimo carlanter Carlo piantatore
Bravi bravi [__] Ah non c'ha la
dinamica al pallone mi Stampo un po' di
tessuti tecnici Già che ci sia una donna
come sono contento ragazzi mi chiamo
Guarda che posto posso anche giustamente
posso anche dormire Beh vedi ehm
oh Salve buongiorno una bella doccia io
Me l'avrei sarai fatta la doccia Ci sono
vestiti nuovi giacca invernale collected
Allora qua ci stanno i bambini morti
facciamoli fuori porca [__]
Ok sembrano poco pericolosi questi qua
ma in realtà son pericolosi ragazzi
perché fanno danno
Ok ok
Boh sono morti tutti teoricamente non
c'era una sega va bene Ah no ashanti
incendio
dove Eccola Uh
è molto meno rapida Ma è molto più forte
Raga ho trovato asce antincendio Vabbè
allora ne è valsa la pena Allora ragazzi
una bella dormita Oh yeah e mi sveglio
domani mattina allora my boys andiamo
direttamente al alla porta
Allora o è Kelvin che fa il pazzo
maniaco Oppure mi devo preoccupare
ragazzi e io ve lo dico tanto c'ho
un'ascia che più grossa de tu madre
Mostrati a me provaci Ah Kevin grazie a
Dio lo vedo Katy Ma sei scemo più cosa
cazzo ridi mi puoi far venire gli
infarti così come si sente fuori Lui
ride non gliene frega niente Guarda Lui
è contento è contento Allora ragazzi
bisogna adesso che ho la tessera
finalmente andare in tutti quei posti
dove tu puoi accedervi solo con la
tessera quindi Sono tutti posti di altri
bunker Il primo che vorrei provare Eh
vabbè che tanto è pieno di bunker in
realtà posso provare Innanzitutto questo
che c'ho davanti e poi ce n'è anche un
altro vicino Io andrei io non so se
posso fare sta cosa Oddio Vabbè dai
proviamoci
raga Fermi sta funzionando sta
funzionando Incredibile è fortissimo Sto
male sto male all'Acquapark l'acquapark
di Sons of the forest bagni Dov'è il
bagnino il bagnino è Kelvin Ragazzi ve
lo dico io No vabbè incredibile che
tecnica che tecnica anni di gioco per
queste cagate Qua comunque guarda guarda
guarda guarda funziona da dio funziona
da Dio sono un [__] genio Ma come non
m'è venuta prima sta cosa
Minchia mi sembra di guardare revenant
Di Caprio Fammi provare a scendere
Oddio
[Musica]
Minchia come lo schivato è stato
terribile ragazzi ho avuto un infarto
non programmato e ci siamo mai buoni
Speriamo che succede in questo bunker
raga perché mi sa che era questo Ragazzi
il bunker quello bello pesante quello
che avevamo trovato all'inizio il primo
con la botola credo eh vediamo
tranquilli pipistrelli Sì era questo me
lo ricordo bene questo Ragazzi era il
primo bunker che abbiamo trovato Negli
scorsi episodi quello dove ho trovato la
porta chiusa a chiave quindi esattamente
il primo Non vorrei che rispondono Gli
oggetti Meno male meno male perché
almeno mi ripiglio un attimo di
cioè di cibo robe Perché
sennò Minchia sarebbe difficile A parte
che l'arco Io vorrei trovare un arco
alla catney severdin fatto per bene
ragazzi Perché minchia Secondo me è
troppo utile Solo che ho solo frecce
però è questa la porta vediamo
Ma chi ha funzionato Meno male poteva
non essere quella la tessera ma a quanto
pare è questa quindi Let's Go My Boy
Ciao ragazzi ci sono piante
bimbi morti mamma Let's go buca uno esci
Riprova fuori campo bellissimo
è finita lascia anche questo questo è
morto Ah per sicurezza ragazzi eh non lo
sapevo che quest'arma fa il suo Ma
questa erbetta è quella che pensi io No
non è quello che penso io Maledetti ma
scarponi lo so cosa fate voi Qua Ma chi
che chi è che ha sparato Ste frecce Vale
dar per Balestra e trovarla la balestra
il problema
non ci credo vi giuro che non lo sapevo
lo giuro non avevo idea che culo Ok
ok bene
mix energetico collected cosa allora io
di darvi per Balestra ne avevo già un
miliardo e mezzo perché è dall'inizio il
gioco che continua a trovarsi di dardi
di merda
e l'ho sparato questo lo posso
riprendere Sì quindi me li fai
riprendere No
merda
[__] cazzo è questo Oh
Ma da dove minchia sei uscito
Oddio non ricaricare
Porca vacca io il tempismo E vabbè
Ma vattene a [__] Minchia quanto dura
oh
[__] Madonna quanto quanto resistente lo
zio
che cazzo ci fai qua dentro è morto è
morto Eh beh però dai
cioè Allora Considerando che ti puoi
riprendere i colpi Minchia è un'arma
devastante luce
bello però grazie dell'infarto gratuito
te lo collected resine Let's go è
fortissima vi cos'è
c'è dell'acqua
hai tutto allagato qua oppure ci manca
solo quello Grazie ragazzi No veramente
Grazie Ci mancava solo l'acquapark l'ho
fatto già prima eh non è che devo fare
per forza tutte le volte ragazzi dove
stiamo Dove sto andando Non lo so c'è
un'altra porta c'è un'altra porta altre
due Anzi aspetta che ci hanno messo
un'altra porta con la tessera non vorrei
che fosse
che non puoi entrare anche qua porca
[__] Lo sapevo no ci sono altre tessere
Raga non è che posso collezionare
tessere all'infinito Eh ragazzi Però che
palle
Ma che cazzo sta succedendo là dentro
cos'è ma in diretta sta roba No ma
Ragazzi ma neanche nei peggio horror ho
visto ste cose Ma cos'è Madonna
terribile Oh l'ho
trovata cos'è Virginia faston Gigi bella
tizia contro le gambe Virginia Fausto
nella tizia con tre gambe sto male vai
la figlia del miliardario come fai ad
averte le gambe allora scusa che mica è
che cazzo è scusa c'è qualcosa di Dimmi
che c'è un indizio One more artifact 2
sono collegati al cubo praticamente loro
erano quasi miliardari per sti artefatti
poi non ho capito che cosa significano
sti artefatti ma lo scopriremo avanti
nel gioco cioè loro sono venuti su
quest'isola credo credo Non lo so per
trovare questi artefatti misteriosi che
non so che cosa siano effettivamente
Però vabbè tra cui appunto Virgi
abbinario per fucile a pompa attenzione
ancora capito che cazzo ne so Ah il
binario per metterci i proiettili sopra
mi sa Ok vediamo Vabbè comunque stavo
dicendo Quindi tu non lo so che cazzo
serve abbinare ragazzi non me ne intendo
così tanto di armi va bene Sì è per
ficcarci i proiettili sopra per essere
più veloce a ricaricare credo sia quello
i miliardario con la figlia la moglie e
i parenti tutt'altro genio ha portato di
tutti quanti così Muoiono tutti per
trovare questi artefatti poi non so cosa
sia successo ma la figlia c'ha tre gambe
Va bene funziona la tessera a Let's go
Vai Boys
Vedo gente grossa se vi alzate vi
frantumo il malleolo soprattutto ad una
donna che schifo
Madonna ragazzi Ma cos'è ma che caccia
due parti Cioè questo tizio ha due ehm
uscite di testa va bene Comunque state
pranzando bello bello fatto bene Eh
almeno voi bellissimi cos'è che c'è qua
dietro eh si può dare qua nell'acqua
vediamo se c'è qualcosa dai
non sembra esserci niente di strano
nell'acqua No non è vero C'è un'entrata
nelle caverne sto male c'è un'entrata
delle caverne da qua vabbè cioè Ormai
non mi stupisco più di niente Raga ma
voi chi è scavato sta roba più vado
avanti e meno capisco c'è una roba
terrificante si esce No sono nelle
caverne una merda A meno che non entro
in un'altra parte del bunker ma dubito
non vedo un cazzo si vede una sega
Ah i miei posti preferiti Buongiorno
allora vattene a [__] Non è che posso
sta qua e quanti siete
Double version my boys c'è gente e vedo
Comunque
basta che cazzo è mica che cazzo sei
Highlander Allora io basta cercare i
colpi del fucile Cioè non è non sto
sprecando Ok però non è che posso sta
qua a fucilare tutti però Ragazzi ma con
la chiave vip Cosa posso aprire Cioè a
parte quella roba lì altri Boom
hai cagato u cazz' Minchia mi ha fatto
malissimo Tra l'altro ragazzi non posso
shottare ovviamente con sta roba forse è
meglio che uso la balestra sai perché la
balestra almeno mi ripiglio le cose che
sparo Ok ragazzi cambia il programma
Minchia è fortissima la balestra Madonna
raga cioè incredibile finalmente le armi
decenti i bambini morti guarda guarda
guarda è pazzesca c'è qualcosa raga c'è
qualcosa c'è qualcuno sento qualcuno c'è
un'uscita c'è un'uscita
potrebbe essere non lo so eh Sono fuori
Tu sei scemo scherzo Non posso fare male
a Kevin di colpa al primo episodio eh eh
Kelvin mentre ti fai selfie Andiamo via
va' che qua non è che posso star tutta
la vita devo andare devo tornare a casa
perché il bunker che c'è vicino a casa
mia del classicone quello dove c'è la
stampante ha un'altra porta
Oh fratello te lo giuro ti faccio
saltare la famiglia te lo giuro vado nei
tuoi accampamenti faccio fuori tutti
tutti
gli scuoio vivi tutti Fatevi i cazzi
vostri
Ti giuro che al prossimo di Lancia una
granata ve lo giuro oh No beh tornare a
casa così è molto semplice ragazzi a sto
punto manco il motorino mi faceva
tornare così in fretta bella Ma vi
rendete conto Virginia Patton era figlia
del del miliardario la tipa la tipa con
tre gambe Geova again siamo arrivati a
questo bunker maledetto della resina del
siamo Allora ragazzi tra una scampagnata
all'altra siamo finalmente arrivati al
punto raga Eh non so Eh adesso che
cacchio vediamo ok raga allora un po' di
soldi rubare
e tesserina Let's go
questa era la prima eh non è la seconda
non era quella bip Buongiorno ha una
paletta Madonna che figo se ti alzi ti
scuoio ma tanto che palestra fighissima
cioè sto male io io in palestra io
Ragazzi c'è una
è diventato The Day Island sto gioco Oh
cioè non andare a fare la cyclette
adesso fermati
[Musica]
ho capito come ho capito la distanza dei
dardi più o meno da quanto devo sparare
in alto ho capito Mi sono regolato
adesso sono tarato e letale Allora
reception desk Madonna ma che posto
pazzesco C'è un sacco di gente sto posto
ragazzi è diventato Resident Evil Qua
c'è gente ci sono indigeni ma di seccoli
secco Che cazzo è è un Gollum doppio
l'ho colpito Eh non so a che testa devo
mirare esattamente
Porca [__] Uh che schifo cioè l'uno sul
vetro sono Tizi ragno
sono tipo dei ragni umani che schifo
aiuto
Beh minchia quanti proiettili servono
Raga per schiattare Però io ho paura che
l'altro se ne torni indietro che schifo
uno è morto ammazzato solo Ah no tutte e
due perfetto eh uno solo alla fine ci
può stare e anche oggi si muore domani
ragazzi Perfetto io vado avanti e più
Sento rumori stranissimi no c'è un'altra
porta ragazzi Dimmi che si apre
ok
e forse era meglio non aprirla Questa
però
lasciamola lì Salve Guarda guarda che
roba una chitarra chitarra Collect No
scusatemi che senso
Ma in che senso
farò sto male ma non sto male ragazzi ma
non ci credo posso dare le chitarrato in
testa alla gente Ma che gioco
incredibile Comunque tutto strano Eh ve
lo dico Madonna Questo è un night club
ah
porcelloni cos'è che fate qua dentro eh
Un musacci un'altra tessera chiave
magnetica per visitatori Arnold grande
chi cazzo è un tizio Vabbè il night club
qui ho tre tessere in totale qua ci
posso passare non ci passo va bene sto
facendo progressi di continuo ma da
questo punto in avanti è molto semplice
fare progressi a quanto pare Ecco credo
che non si suoni così la chitarra però
vabbè vediamo se riesco a far di meglio
Aoh Deck adesso sta chitarra
e adesso ci sono tutta la compilation
dei Queen testo sta di culo
o schitarrate e non muore Oh
quanto tempo per morire
e muori
vai che ti sono le canzoni dei film lei
Eh allora le scuole dello sfogliarle
tutte perché sennò non ho armatura
ragazzi alla fine l'armatura più comune
è questa qua Allora direi che è forte la
chitarra ma non quanto la balestra
Quindi abbiamo provata però andrei di
Balestra ragazzi e vediamo se
Madonna sono diventato espertissimo
Salve non l'avevo vista lei mi scusi
Allora uno ormai niente mi ha visto devo
seccarlo Ragazzi ma ce la farò Eccolo
Eccola la carica
Porca [__] che male tre
aspetta zio
fuori morto Ah non è morto non muore con
quattro colpi di solito
5 Che schifo Ma cos'è che sputa ogni
volta
Che schifo ragazzi sti affari vanno
veramente schifo e la cosa più brusio di
sto gioco ve lo dico allora
Ah ce la sala cinema mancava solo questo
raga ormai
bibite bevande energetiche ho fame o se
ragazzi devo pure è una stanza
insonorizzata
Ma ragazzi Ma che cazzo dite ma
Scusatemi ma cosa sta succedendo in
questo gioco questa roba va a benzina
cos'è Come faccio a utilizzarla deve
ricaricarla Ah ecco mi dice molto a pile
la motosega pile io l'ho mai visto una
cosa del genere non l'ho mai vista la
motosega pile raga Sto malissimo va bene
cereali
in tutto questo trovate a destra che non
ho capito a cosa mi possa servire però
tre tessere Quindi con questa
teoricamente ci apro un qualcos'altro
non so cosa allora teoricamente unico
Auri Qua si esce lo so perché senti i
passi di Kelvin questo è sempre una
garanzia ecco qua teoricamente Questa è
un'uscita
teoricamente perché quando c'è questo
strapiombo qua in genere è uscita
Let's go vediamo se riusciamo non so
dove non so dove sto uscendo Non ho idea
Kelvin sei qua Ok Viene qua perfetto
dov'è che siamo Oh molto vicini molto
vicini Va bene allora
che cazzo è successo ma avete visto
anche voi Boh non ho per una
Ragazzi ma che cazzo sta succedendo
cos'è che c'è Kevin Ma lo vedi anche tu
mi si sono creati gli alberi dal nulla
ma che cazzo è successo Allora ragazzi
torniamo al nostro rifugio a questo
punto visto che abbiamo sete fame e
tutto il resto andiamo a dormire e lì
Domani andremo a guardare cosa si può
aprire con la tessera numero 3 che
effettivamente credo che siate sta per
andare avanti nel gioco ci sono un altro
paio di posti che ancora sono chiusi con
le porte e andiamo a vedere quelli e
teoricamente lo sviluppo del gioco sta
andando benissimo ragazzi cioè io sto
scoprendo tutto sto giocando bene per
una volta la mia vita sto giocando un
gioco decentemente incredibile e ci
siamo my boys salvataggio Let's Go
Oh che cazzo è
perché c'è gente non mi fa dormire Non
ho capito posso dormire frate ho sonno
voglio dormire Ho sonno
dormire allora aspetti spiego Allora
guarda ti spiego Ti spiego Adesso adesso
vado a dormire Arrivederci Buonanotte
dormire
oh ah Siete stronzi
ce l'ho fatta Oh
santo Iddio incredibile Sì ragazzi
Eccolo qui anche questo episodio di
thefork Sons
è colpa mia non so fare lo youtuber ci
saranno ancora sicuramente un sacco a
scoprire Fatemi sapere se il video Vi è
piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale lasciate
un commento qua sotto e noi ci vediamo
con un prossimo episodio di Sons of the
forest Beh ragazzi